>>Principal: Couple of things
we're gonna cover today.
One is a midday block
schedule for next year,
so we could actually
start planning now.
>>Narrator: It's not easy
being a principal these days.
Among other things, you've
got to be a financial wizard.
>>Rich: Well, I think we need
to look at what the priorities
in the budget are gonna be.
>>Narrator: A savvy politician.
>>Principal: -- back from Bell
South Foundation for our grant.
>>Narrator: And an
educational visionary.
>>There has to be exploration
and it has to be decided
by the children, not by the teachers.
>>Narrator: And you've
also go to know what to do
with the kid who's throwing
food in the cafeteria.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Woman: Since I saw you last and
actually talked to you about that,
he had to throw a slushie
clear across the cafeteria.
>>Rich: Oh no.
>>Narrator: With daily
challenges and mounting pressures,
it's perhaps not surprising
that forty percent
of current principals are planning
to retire in the next decade.
>>Woman: So what do you think
we should do with him now?
>>Rich: We can sit down with him,
because we just can't have this kind
of behavior happening,
at a constant level.
>>Narrator: Problem solving
is nothing new to Rich Kuder,
who spent years as a classroom
teacher and assistant principal.
But in his first year as principal of
Eisenhower Middle School in Wyckoff,
New Jersey, he has to come up with
all the right answers all the time.
>>Teacher: Keep the
kids in the center
and start the cut from the outside.
>>Rich: As a first year
principal, you have to get a sense
of the culture, of how
things are done in a school.
You know, there's sort of the
written rules about how things work
and then there's the unwritten
rules about how things work,
and you really need to be attuned
to those, and work not only
to understand it, but
then also if need be,
change some of those
operating assumptions.
>>Teacher: Okay, very good.
>>Jim: You certainly need a person
who can think on their feet,
and come to creative solutions.
>>Rich: But there's a slight
itinerary change in the Philly trip.
>>Jim: A good leader is a
person who can relate to people
and have them come along on a
mission, have them grab on and engage
with that mission and
see it to its finality.
>>Narrator: Fortunately,
Kuder has been able to turn
to another principal
for critical advice.
>>Tony: Okay, you get the idea?
Okay, don't raise your hand.
Just kinda look at me.
I can read your faces.
So--
>>Narrator: His former
boss, Tony Bencivenga,
is principal at Ben Franklin
Middle School in nearby Ridgewood,
and every few weeks,
Bencivenga visits his protege
to renew their friendship
and continue their informal
mentorship arrangement.
>>Tony: How are the
kids doing, all right?
>>Rich: Yeah, they're doing great.
>>Tony: Good.
>>Narrator: One of the most
successful programs Kuder has brought
to Eisenhower is a
daily news broadcast,
patterned after a program he launched
with his mentor at Ben Franklin.
>>Boy: Eisenhower wishes farewell to
Emily Murphy as she moves to Oakland.
Best wishes--
>>Tony: You've been live every day
since the beginning of the year?
>>Rich: Yeah, I mean a few
days into the year, you know,
we started going with a live show.
>>Tony: Right, right.
>>Rich: Every day.
>>Tony: Every day.
>>Tony: The children, they're
really directing their learning.
>>Rich: This is about
them, the opportunity
to do this is really up to them.
They understand what needs
to do in order to get a show
out and to do a great job.
And they work and critique
themselves.
>>Tony: That's the authentic
assessment we talked about.
And how about project based learning?
You know, you're talking
about working on a project.
This is project based
learning every day.
>>Rich: Every student that's in here
at eight thirty tomorrow morning
will have an opportunity to say like,
"You know what, I really
did something today.
A real thing.
Everybody saw my broadcast."
>>Tony: Exactly.
>>Rich: This was a
great accomplishment.
>>Tony: Right, right.
>>You don't work with a teleprompter?
You--
>>Rich: No, we don't
work with a teleprompter.
>>Tony: Because you
know, we don't either.
And I think you and
I talked about that.
>>Rich: Well, and again, that's
kind of a conscious decision.
>>Rich: You need somebody
to bounce things off of.
It's wonderful to have
someone, a friend like Tony,
who will be up front and honest
with you about, you know,
"Well, I think you're right.
I think your line of thinking
is right on the money," or,
"Have you considered this
about your position?"
>>Rich: So it's been
a great relationship.
It's been really beneficial for me.
>>Tony: And what you always talked
about, the reality based learning.
This is a perfect example of it.
>>Teacher: We have the
geographical location,
geology, climate, living things.
>>Narrator: Kuder inherited
a highly rated school.
His challenge is to maintain
the current high standards while
advancing his personal agenda.
>>Rich: It sounds to me like what
you're working on is ambitious
and appropriate, so I
would go with that unless--
>>As a principal, I have tried to
articulate my vision with my staff,
meeting the individual needs of
kids, attending to the social
and emotional needs of kids,
providing strong reality
based programs,
infusing technology
into the curriculum.
Even in our faculty meetings,
we spend time talking about,
what does it mean to have a culture
in your classroom where kids feel
like they're accepted, where they
feel safe, where they can take risks?
>>Teacher: You'll be
working cooperatively
in groups to accomplish this task.
You gotta find the name of the
person, date of birth and death,
their revolutionary role and their
major beliefs and accomplishments.
All right, so we'll
go to that home page.
All right, the time, you
will have twenty minutes
to get this accomplished.
>>Student: Oh, here we go.
>>Student: It says that
the most important thing
in society is the way
people earn their money.
>>Student: Bolsheviks came
to power, blah, blah, blah.
The orthodox church was an enemy.
So they helped the czar of Russia.
>>Narrator: Monitoring this sixth
grade Russian history lesson,
Kuder sees his educational
vision come to life.
>>Student: Like after he was
banished from the Soviet Union,
he criticized Stalin's
rule, like a lot,
and then he was assassined
in Mexico in 1940.
>>Teacher: Okay, very good.
Very good job, Josh.
>>Narrator: During a
quick brown bag lunch,
Kuder enjoys a stress
reduction ritual he picked
up from his old boss, indulging
in a rerun of "The Honeymooners."
>>Tony: There he is.
>>Ralph Kramden: There'll
be no snoozing.
Norton, I said don't snooze.
>>Tony: How're things going?
>>Rich: All right.
>>We're working on
staffing for next year.
We have an incoming sixth grade
class next year of over two hundred
and eighty kids, and so
we're looking at, you know,
how to keep class sizes manageable.
>>Tony: We have a similar
problem with the staffing.
The dilemma I'm facing right
now is, what's more critical,
the seventh grade or the sixth grade?
And my feeling is that maybe
the transition from fifth
to sixth is the more critical
moment, and I really need--
>>The joy of what I do
and the joy that I know
that Rich feels is the joy
of being with the kids.
>>Rich: You guys okay?
>>Student: Yep.
>>Tony: I've been in education for
thirty five years and I still get
up in the morning, knowing that
I'm gonna face a challenging day,
but I'm gonna face a great day.
It's gonna be an exciting
day, watching the kids learn.
>>I am so proud of what
you all do in this school.
>>To watch children learn and grow
and be happy is very rewarding.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.